let's pretend this is a safe space
sharing intimate secrets with coworkers
can bond us together an increased
communication in the workplace now who
wants to share first I never admitted
this before but I hate my grandkids just
suck one time I hit a deer with my car
because I wanted to look I'm just gonna
say this I am a cutter and that works
for me and that's when I realized I had
inadvertently helped do 9/11 so so great
gorgeous let's all give Ted a big round
of applause and help support Ted okay
seems like everyone is shared
except for you Matt Matt why some shot
oh yeah I don't really know if this is
for me I might just go for a swim come
on Matt we've all shared with each other
except for you
just tell us something simple be
confident like how did you lose your
virginity oh okay
well I was in college and it was
Halloween night and we were watching a
movie spooky what movie I'd rather not
say come on come on it was hocus-pocus
excellent film anyway I got distracted
by the movie and it lasted way too long
and that's the end of that story no no
no no it's not Matt we got to go way way
deep wait
I fully trust you with my heart and mind
- close shave me with a straightedge
razor I accept and honor your trust and
wish you the very best of luck well look
who's here oh sorry cliff but you moved
didn't think you were the trust shave
team-building type oh so you were
thinking about me now I have a personal
tidbit to put about you my Excel
spreadsheet thinks about Jake oh wow and
I have something to put about you and my
Google Doc suffers from narcissistic
personality disorder you want to get out
of here
fine twist my arm Jake I fully trust you
with my heart in mind and then Bette
Midler's sang a Broadway rendition of I
put a spell on you and the night
[Applause]
wrap your arms around his neck and love
[Music]
you